hello to miss Reeves it's good to see
you thanks for joining us on the program
I bet you're enjoying this contest
aren't you good morning to me
I bet you're enjoying this contest
the conservatives are obviously ripping
shreds out of each other at the moment
but my big worry about the conservative
party leadership contest is that it is
so small compared to the challenges we
face as a country
um whether those are the day-to-day
challenges of being able to get a
passport and then to actually get out of
the country if you're successful in
getting one the challenges are getting a
Hospital appointment or a doctor's
appointment or indeed the cost of living
crisis which is people's number one
concern right now especially ahead of
the October increase in Energy prices
and it just feels to me that neither of
the two remaining contenders for the
conservative leadership really have
answers to the big challenges we face as
a country
um from Labor's calculations can Liz
truss cut taxes by
um 30 billion pounds
I don't see how those numbers stack up
and it will be interesting to see
whoever wins the contest whether what
they do as prime minister might be a
little bit different to what they
promised during a leadership contest I
if you promise big tax cuts you've got
to be honest and say where the money's
going to come from it either has to come
from further cuts to public spending and
if you look at the report today from the
health select committee and I think
you've had Jeremy Hunt on the program
that shows that the Health Service is on
its knees with no plan to get the
doctors and nurses and and others to
provide the Essential Health Care that
we need all the money has to come from
higher borrowing which will put further
pressure on inflation and interest rates
and I don't think that either candidate
are being responsible in saying how
they're going to fund the things that
they are promising
um in 2023 rate of corporation tax
um which is of course um paid on company
profits due to increased
I think to 25 from 90 let's trust that
she won't do that she'll scrap that rise
what would labor do
well my priority and I've said this
before my priority in terms of business
taxation would be to reduce business
rates because business rates are the
biggest burden on small businesses and
High Street businesses and business
rates are paid before you make a penny
of turnover let alone a penny of profit
so as Chancellor my focus would be on
reducing the burden of business rates on
smaller businesses and higher High
Street businesses that would be a bigger
priority for me than corporation tax
cuts and I've explained how we would
fund those cuts in business rates uh by
for example extending the Digital
Services tax to bring in more revenue
and by taxing those global global
multinationals who make huge profits but
very rarely pay taxes in the countries
in which they operate that's a very
different strategy from what we're
seeing from the conservative leadership
contenders who as I said it promised
Cuts but don't explain where the money
is going to come from no but last year
last March labor did say it would back a
gradual increase in corporation tax are
you still backing that
well look those are the plans at the
moment and we supported those plans as I
say in terms of reducing the burden of
Taxation on businesses my priority would
be to help smaller businesses and High
Street businesses rather than
um that approach that the conservatives
are taking but look with all these
things it's one thing to promise things
during a conservative leadership contest
I would want to see from whoever's the
next prime minister the detailed and
costed plans that they've got and then
we'll take a view of them when they come
but at the moment I just feel the
candidates are promising whatever they
think is needed to win a leadership
contest within their own party rather
than the um the policies and the
strategies that are needed to grow our
economy and that's the focus of Kia
stalma's speech today of how we're going
to actually grow our economy because
over the last 10 years or so the economy
has flatlined with growth bumping along
next year there are growth forecasts say
that we are going to have the slowest
growth in the G20 apart from Russia and
that we're going to have the highest
inflation in the G7 and that is
disastrous for the British economy it's
the worst of Both Worlds where you have
inflation high and rising and growth low
and falling we've got to get out of this
vicious spiral and actually have a
serious plan for boosting growth and
that's what Kia's speaking about today
okay so what would you do about a
National Insurance increase would you
scrap it
oh when we had the National Insurance uh
increase uh proposals come to Parliament
labor MPS voted against it Rishi sunak
introduced it and Liz Charles voted for
it Liz trust is now a convert to our way
of thinking which was to say that
National Insurance contribution
increases was the wrong tax at the wrong
time right in the middle of a cost of
living crisis so we wouldn't have had
the National Insurance contribution
increase yeah but if people lost raising
12 billion quid a year isn't it for
social care in the NHS so where would
that money come from
well the the they the the chancellor got
rid of half of his uh increase in
National Insurance contributions so it
wouldn't raise uh quite that amount of
money but it doesn't seem right to me uh
that it is almost working people under
the conservatives that are bearing the
burden of Taxation it's why I've set out
some targeted tax increases on the very
wealthy so we've said that we would
abolish the non-dom tax status because
if you make Britain your home you should
pay your taxes here we've said that if
you're a private Equity boss your
bonuses should be treated as income and
not as capital gains and if you send
your children to private school and you
uh have the ability to afford those fees
that there should be VAT on those school
fees and so those are some of the things
we would do to make our tax system
fairer whereas under the conservatives
with the 15 tax Rises we've seen in the
last two years the burden of Taxation
Falls time and time again on ordinary
working people and that is not right
it's not fair and during the cost of
living crisis it makes no economic sense
to do that either but to talk to you
Rachel Reeves as always thank you